this Aussie is an absolute Legend with
pretty thick and pumped right now heads
up going straight in there nice and hard
and I'll see what we got and deliver
when Oliver dick Stacy Tierney qualified
for the 2019 cattle major the world
rejoiced not because it was an amazing
achievement it was but more importantly
he would be able to make a sticker to
Forever immortalize his name a sticker
with the word dick on it however dick
Stacy had bigger dreams he wanted his
sticker to include well I think if you
use your imagination you can find out
what it is unfortunately Bob wasn't too
thrilled with his uh first rendition
dick Stacy did the only reasonable thing
there was to do in such a predicament he
asked his mom for help but even with the
aid of his mother's artistic skills
valve rejected the design yet again the
clock was running down so he gripped his
pencil and gave us a signature that
everyone could get behind short sweet
and to the point